okay so joe biden's big move is to do
exactly what donald trump did but not
xenophobic like right he's gonna do a
travel ban and that's supposed to fix
everything here is um the problem um
it's not going to work and the reason
it's not going to work is because it's
already seated here
okay so the bite administration is
trying to double down on boosters at
this point
um again the data on omicron
is not sufficient to say that a 30 year
old needs a booster shot at this point
uh fauci said it is conceivable if not
likely that booster shots will provide
at least a partial shield of protection
against the new variant he did not cite
any data to to explain why he said that
that is the case
also the experts are saying uh yeah by
the way these these um
these travel
bans are not really going to to do
anything uh fauci has said it is highly
unlikely that vaccines offer no
protection against the new variant the
who says it says it's working with a
large number of researchers around the
world to understand the impact omicron
would have on existing vaccines and
antivirals
so they don't even know you know what
this thing does to the to the vaccine at
this point and they're like well what if
we just keep shooting you full of of
more vaccine how about we find out what
it does first i know it's kind of crazy
to suggest that maybe we should be
guided by data as opposed to just like
randomly jabbing people at this point
again i'm very pro-vaccine but i like
data also and you've provided me no data
sir so this is unhelpful as far as the
travel bans so joe biden remember not a
xenophobe he's not
he's a different old white guy than the
last old white guy he is not xenophobic
so um fauci comes out he's like yeah
maybe it's already here which is awkward
for us a little
is it possible it's already in the u.s
you know
of course anything is possible we don't
know that there's no indication that it
is right now it seemed to have been
restricted there were some cases
that originated in south africa and that
went to botswana and people who traveled
and found out they were infected and one
that had gone actually to hong kong so
there's a lot of travel you never know
exactly where we are and that's the
reason why we're getting together to
them to try and get the precise
molecular makeup of it so you could
actually test for it
okay meanwhile fauci is trying to so so
he's saying it's probably already here
and then he's like oh yeah but maybe the
maybe the travel bans will buy us some
time
uh will they explain
you know it will slow things down george
travel bans when you have a highly uh
transmissible virus
never completely would get the virus to
coming uh prevent it from coming into
the country no way that's gonna happen
but what what you can do is you can
delay it enough to get us better
prepared and that's the thing that
people need to understand if you're
gonna do the travel ban the way we've
done now and that we're implementing
right now utilize the time that you're
buying to fill in the gaps
okay so um
maybe that's true and maybe it's not i
will say that a travel ban that is
geared toward south africa alone and not
toward anybody who has traveled to south
africa or from south africa and and
people who have been with those people
like once it's already widely seated
it's a little bit late for that but
again it's not xenophobia unless donald
trump does it is the rule voucher by the
way again he just keeps throwing out all
of these maybes and the babies are
designed to scare the crap out of you so
now he's saying well maybe we'll do a
vax mandate uh to just travel to get on
a plane now again this is insane the
reason it's insane is because
the the planes have been like one of the
safest places this entire pandemic
they've got the hepa filters okay planes
have not been a central vehicle for
transmission of the virus throughout the
entire pandemic
which was counter to what a lot of
people thought no evidence was ever
provided that that if you were on a
plane with a lot of other people that
you were more likely to get this than if
you were at a crowded grocery store for
example
but anthony fauci is now saying maybe
we'll force you to get the vax so that
you will get on a plane come on
right now we hope that people who get
vaccinated and who will follow the
appropriate recommendations that air
travel will continue to be safe and
right now air travel is when you say
travel in general causes a risk of
increased transmission it's the whole
process of traveling going to the
airport being in an airport in
congregate setting people taking their
masks off that's the issue that we've
got to make sure that we adhere to more
more closely and more firmly
okay so in other words it's not the
planes but we might force you to fax
anyway to get on a plane because you
know it's the whole process of travel oh
you mean like life
oh yeah it's it's true like life is a
process in which travel is a part he's
like well it's not just the travel so
you know you're at the airport and then
you're in the car before you go to the
airport and then go to marshalls to pick
up a suitcase in order so you can go to
the airport and then when you get off
the plane at the airport you might be
hungry so you go to a restaurant you
pick up some chop suey like what are you
talking about what are you talking about
why would you let these
jackasses run your life why what
evidence have they provided to you that
they are good at this any okay so faulty
was then asked about um
representing science because he was
saying like why are you attacked why are
you attacked dr fauci these are always
the question he's asked by our legacy
media instead of being asked why do you
shift your opinion every five seconds
why do you seem to do the bidding of the
biden administration while rolling your
eyes during trump press conferences why
is it that you're willing to trot out
whatever propagandistic line joe biden
is trotting out today
and why is it that we should listen to
you after you've gotten every element of
this wrong at some point during the
pandemic you've provided no forecasting
ability whatsoever you haven't even
provided diagnostic ability throughout
this pandemic the data you've provided
have been counter counterproductive
you've lost the trust of the american
people instead of asking actual tough
questions the legacy means you're like
why are people so mean to you dr fauci
can we make another founding documentary
that shows a picture of you in your home
on your computer with a giant poster of
you next to you
by the way that is one i'm never to
understand and
dead giveaway that somebody is a
douchebag is if there is a picture of
them in their house with a giant picture
of them right next to them dead giveaway
or a douchebag we're not talking about
like a family picture with you and the
rest of the members of your family sound
like a portrait of you next to you
okay i like
that is the douchebag giveaway
go check out his documentary it is there
anyway here is dr anthony fauci being
asked about why he's criticized and his
answer is of course because he is
science he is
like like emperor palpatine is the
senate he is the science
well if they get up and criticize
science nobody's gonna know what they're
talking about
but if they get up and really aim their
bullets at tony fauci well people could
recognize there's a person there so it's
easy to criticize but they're really
criticizing science
because i represent science
that's dangerous to me that's more
dangerous
than the slings and the arrows that get
thrown at me
okay so i have a question when you
criticize jay bhattacharya from stanford
when you criticize marti mkhari from
johns hopkins university when you
criticize scott atlas from stanford when
you when you criticize all those people
are you are you attacking the science or
are you just attacking a particular
scientific perspective on the data why
is it that only anthony fauci is the
science why is he the voice of science
he's bad at this he's just bad at this
okay and then he's asked specifically
about the idea of being prosecuted okay
so there have been a lot of republicans
ted cruz rand paul who suggested that
anthony fauci lied to them about gain of
function research in wuhan which he kind
of did the way that he has avoided the
actual perjury question is by redefining
gain of function cogain of function
typically means according to anthony
fauci that you increase the
transmissibility of a virus within a
species it doesn't mean that you make a
virus transmissible across species and
now that is a really formal definition
of gain of function research that does
not meet the smell test but that's what
anthony thought she's been relying upon
so rand paul and ted cruz have been
going after him and anthony fauci is
asked about this and he gets super
pissed and then cackles like like a bond
villain here
senator cruz told the attorney general
you should be prosecuted yeah
i have to laugh at that
i should be prosecuted
do you think that this is
about making you a scapegoat to deflect
of course president trump of course
you have to be asleep not to figure that
one out well there are a lot of
republican senators uh taking aim
at this right that's okay i'm just going
to do my job
and i'm going to be saving lives and
they're going to be lying
i'm going to be saving okay
how many lives has anthony fought you
saved
really
how many
also i love that my favorite is
humorless laughs humorous less are some
of my favorites so when you're asked a
question you don't like the question and
so you just sort of laugh but there's no
laughter in the eyes that's my favorite
kind of political after tamil harris is
really good at it that's when we like
laugh and it's like this
love that from anthony fauci
what about january said what about
january sex hell are you talking about
we're talking about whether you lied
about gain of function research in muhan
and whether you suck at your job that's
what we're talking about right now what
the hell does that have to do with trump
what a political hack he is remember
that time when he was not a political
hack or was supposed to not be yeah he's
a political hack but we should always
listen to these people they're the
experts remember they've provided you no
data that omicron is more deadly or that
it will lead to your hospitalization we
they provide no data the vaccines don't
stand up to omicron they've provided no
data whatsoever that natural immunity
doesn't provide any protection against
hospitalization or death from a micron
but listen to them because they will
laugh at you if not and they are the
science if you fall for this one
honestly we're a civilization that gets
what we deserve if we have decided to
worship at the altar of idols like
anthony fauci rather than looking at
actual hard data that they refuse to
provide
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang